sabemos quiero saludar en este momento a
michael schifter ex presidente de inter
american dialogue gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros son michael en directo
américa muy buen día para usted que
balance podemos hacer de esta asamblea
general de la onu
bueno yo creo que
hay una oportunidad para los líderes del
mundo para plantear su agenda sus
prioridades creo que no había gran
sorpresa granada antes pero creo que fue
importante
expresar y compartir las preocupaciones
sobre todo como usted mencionó con el
comet que ha sido tenía un impacto muy
fuerte sobre todo la región de américa
latina que yo sigo muy de cerca
y también el cambio climático que es una
crisis que afecta a todo el mundo pero
había distintas visiones puntos de vista
en cómo manejar ese tema de cambio
climático y quién debería asumir la
responsabilidad también hubo mucho
interés en el discurso de presidente de
baile pues su primero como presidente de
eeuu ante la onu y creo que resaltó la
importancia y diplomacia pero el el tema
que no mencionó en su discurso pero que
fue obviamente muy presente fue el tema
de china
y preocupación en muchos de del mundo
que podría haber un tipo de
enfrentamiento y mucha atención entre
eeuu y chile esto fue que no fue hablado
directamente pero creo que todo el mundo
entendía que esto esto fue un tema muy
importante ahora michael hablemos
entonces de américa latina donde también
fue el primer discurso del presidente
recién electo hace unos meses de perú
pedro castillo además este discurso
cuales otros ustedes resaltaría también
pues el del presidente de nicolás maduro
pues hubo hubo varios discursos que
llamaron la atención pero quiero saber
su opinión al respecto
bueno yo creo que para presente castillo
fue muy importante que llegó al nación
los sonidos y te aclaro su condena al
terrorismo porque en perú
hay mucha controversia de algunos
miembros del gabinete con vínculos o
simpatías concender el luminoso
entonces yo creo que tener una posición
muy clara y contundente expresada ante
el mundo es muy importante aparecer el
otro premio presidente que hizo un
discurso fue presidente ecuador y 10mo
lastró quien enfatizó el tema la crisis
de la migración venezolana el que está
afectando toda la región y también la
importancia de volver a tomar el tiempo
de comercio en la región y jair
bolsonaro deberá decidir el no dio
grandes sorpresas mantuvo su posición
muy dura con respecto al cover una
posición digamos no gran respaldo para
la vacunación
y una una planteamiento bastante
conservador es bastante derecha él es un
populista el presidente de thales y el
que va a la reelección en lan que viene
llevando que el presidente de colombia
planteó la importancia de la comunidad
financiera internacional de comprender
mejor los grandes problemas de la
pandemia y cómo afecta en las financias
las finanzas
en los países que muchos están
endeudados por por por por gastar mucho
con para para hacer mucho gasto social
con respecto a la pandemia y la
población que está muy afectado nicolás
maduro no dio grandes sorpresas de
condenarla
el bloqueo de eeuu hacia cuba responda
la curva y obtener una posición bastante
combativa
el presidente de argentina alberto
fernández también que resaltó el por
importancia de la duda él tiene como el
que tiene tiempo como 50 billones de
dólares duda 2 en el fondo monetario
internacional y él planteó la
importancia de tener una posición mucho
más flexible mucho más sensible a los
países que están bajo ese cargo entonces
yo creo que había una
distintos discursos muy variados pero
los temas principales fueron el tema de
el code
en la región eso eso precisamente quería
hablar con ustedes de michael hablando
de la pandemia de kobe 19 cuáles fueron
las conclusiones más importantes de esta
asamblea número 76 de la onu en que
digamos se basaron los mandatarios y que
a qué conclusiones llegaron que
realmente se puedan llevar a cabo para
acabar de una vez con esta pandemia y
también prevenir futuras no
pero yo creo que yo creo que hubo
planteamientos bastante generales de un
compromiso de los países para tomar
medidas y acciones importantes en cuanto
a producir el efecto cambio climático el
tema que fue resaltado por varios
estados sobre todo el de bolivia luis
arce pues que bueno los países
desarrollados sobre todo eeuu y tiene
que tienen mayor es consultar para hacer
mucho más frente a este tema ahora
rápidamente michael me quedan dos temas
la situación en afganistán y también la
polémica sobre el pacto de seguridad
autos hablemos primero las reuniones
paralelas que se dieron en esta asamblea
general sobre este pacto de seguridad y
después rápidamente la situación en
afganistán
en el pacto de seguridad obviamente el
tema ahí es el es tratar de consolidar
una alianza con respecto al contener
china y esto esto es algo que está dando
mucha importancia en la administración
byron y eso está muy vinculado con el
british en la visión de retiro de la
presencia de tropas estadounidenses en
afganistán o sea que esto no fue un tema
prioritario y tuvo que tomar decisión
pero lo que sí es un tema prioritario
urgente para administración bayern es el
ese papel de china en américa latina y
este pacto creo que refleja el
compromiso de la voluntad de esta
administración para poner mucho más
entonces de consolidar países y
gobiernos con efe actual china